[Music]
there's been another shocking twist in
the murder case that inspired the hit
podcast serial nearly a decade ago Adnan
Syed was sentenced 23 years ago to life
in prison for the killing of his
ex-girlfriend he was freed last year
after the podcast raised doubts about
the case against him now an appeals
court has effectively restored his
conviction the judges ruled yesterday
that there should be a new hearing on
the motion to vacate which would land
Saad back in court our national
correspondent jarika Duncan has more
spent 22 years more than half of his
life behind bars for the murder of his
former high school girlfriend hey Minh
Lee for years he proclaimed his
innocence most notably during phone
calls from prison recorded for the 2014
podcast serial whatever the motivation
is to kill someone when I had absolutely
it didn't exist to me
he finally walked free this past
September after a hearing where his
murder conviction and life sentence were
vacated but the victim's family says
they were blindsided by that hearing
only having time to participate via Zoom
they were told that the state did not
have confidence in the conviction and
therefore moved to vacate the conviction
with one day's notice to the family
there was no transparency with respect
to the new evidence that the state
claims to have on Tuesday the Appellate
Court of Maryland agreed that the short
notice violated the state's victims
rights laws and ordered a new hearing
that in turn reinstated syed's murder
conviction the ruling has been stayed
for 60 days while both sides consider
their next steps all we're talking about
here is whether or not the trial court
complied with Maryland law none of this
means that he's going back to jail in
the short or long term science legal
team plans to appeal the reinstated
conviction to the state supreme court
Syed himself is said to be taking the
news in stride Adnan has a life outside
of prison now he works he visits his
family he takes care of his sick parents
and he's going to continue to do that
he's going to continue to live his life
Lee's family hopes this new hearing will
show them why science conviction was
vacated and perhaps lead to some closure
for the first time we and the world will
get an opportunity to see that evidence
and examine that evidence if odden on
Syed is in fact innocent we would want
to know that as much as anyone else
now if there is a new hearing the
victim's family will be able to again
see what evidence the state used to
vacate syed's conviction the family's
attorney says they also will be ready to
fight for their right to challenge the
evidence presented guess we'll have to
wait and see what happens jerika thank
you so much